I don't know if anyone has heard of a
youtube channel called veritasium it's a
science channel there's a guy on it
named Derek Muller who I I quite enjoy
watching he's got a great explaining
voice and he actually studied at the
same university I studied out even
though he's American she came to mr.
Sydney long story anyway so he always
says you should lead with awesome so
rather than start with like Oh a basic
idea and like develop and taking them
some piece of time and then like ahh
he's the cool thing he's like we just
should start with the cool thing of them
and then use that as your kind of
motivation for the rest of it okay so
i'll make sure to watch carefully I want
you to watch I'm gonna do the best that
I can not really controlled situations
okay uh but I want you to watch I think
I've got enough to do this twice but I
guess we'll find out in a second I want
you to watch and I just want you to
observe observe everything you can rock
and tell you what to observe because i
think that would kind of ruin part of it
but i want you to just see watch and
let's try and draw some conclusions from
it so ya see how well I can do this okay
be sure don't try this at home actually
you can't try a term takase just water
by so you don't have one of these at
home okay so let's try this not too high
I guess
okay so what did you observe apart from
water what what did you upset now I'm
gonna get you to I'm gonna leave that
there for a minute you can you can you
can have a look at it you can think
about what just happened I guess I
didn't plan for it to be exactly that
amount of water but it turned out to be
just about right okay and on your own
page I'd like you to write down a few
things that you notice anything you like
try to be as a zone as you can
unfortunately I don't have enough water
to go and do this again maybe that's a
good thing okay but write down as many
as you can from what you watched how
long does it take maybe 15-20 seconds
something like that while it's still
fresh in your mind right everything that
you saw anything you think was
interesting or unusual or noteworthy
give you about a minute to do that
No